[موسيقى]
أحبك وأحب لوكا ، أنا فقط لا
أريد سمكة على
ما يرام ، لذلك هذا فيديو
لزوجي وهو يتفاوض مع
طفلينا سيينا ولوكا البالغان من العمر خمسة وثلاث سنوات
حول الحصول على سمكة
، نعم ومن سيهتم  من
الأسماك
التي تعتني بي يا
أمي ،
هذا صحيح ،
لذا فهذه بعض من حياتي الواقعية الحياة
التي لا تراها على شبكة CNN ،
لذا فأنا أتعلم يوميًا وأقول
إنه يوم ناجح عندما لا
أفشل تمامًا  على وجهي ،
نصيحة الأبوة 101 لا تدع أطفالك
يأكلون العشاء أمام التلفزيون ، من
الواضح أننا لا نفعل ذلك في هذا المنزل ،
عزيزي ،
لا أريدك أبدًا أن تعرف أنني
بعيد جدًا عن والد مثالي وقد
صنعت  الكثير من الأخطاء على طول الطريق
بما في ذلك التحديق في طريق هاتفي
كثيرًا أمام أطفالي ، لكنني
تحسنت قليلاً وأدركت
أن الأخبار يمكن أن تنتظر معظم الوقت
، لذا إليك بعض الأشياء التي
ساعدني
على طول الطريق ،
فأنا أجعل هذا جميلًا ،
إليك النصيحة الأولى ،
إنه صعب ولكن  لا تقل لا طوال الوقت ،
امنح أطفالك بعض الوكالات
حتى لا أريد السمكة ، يا
أبي ،
أنت بحاجة إلى
معطف هو ذلك
السمكة التي حصلنا عليها ،
لكنني تفاوضت معها
من ببغاء  ببغاء ، أريد
ببغاءًا لذلك الزقزقة ، مثل الكثير من الآباء ،
لديّ كتب bazillion عن الأبوة
والأمومة ولم أقرأ أيًا منها تقريبًا
لأنك بصفتك أحد الوالدين ليس لديك وقت
لقراءة هذه الكتب حول كيف تكون أبًا أفضل
ولكن  لقد قرأت هذا الكتاب ،
يُدعى كيفية تربية الأشخاص الناجحين من قبل
إستر راجيكي ، لقد ساعدني حقًا ،
إنها بالمناسبة كانت جميلة الآن منذ فترة طويلة
مدرسًا ثانويًا مشهورًا في بالو
ألتو وبناتها الثلاث
ناجحات بشكل كبير ،
فكيف كانت  تربي هؤلاء
النساء الثلاث الناجحات المستقلات ، وتقول إن
الكثير من الهياكل لا تبشر بالخير
للأطفال ، عليك أن تمنحهم بعضًا منها ، لكن
لا يمكنك أن تأمرهم بالقيام بالأشياء طوال
الوقت.
القواعد في المنزل ولكن
الصراخ لا على أطفالنا جميعًا  في يوم
من الأيام ، لم يكن ذلك يقودنا حقًا إلى أي مكان
تكتب فيه أيضًا عن التعاون مع
طفلك وتقول إن التحدث إلى
طفلك كمتعاون يجعله يشعر
وكأنه جزء من الفريق وهذا ما
يجب أن تكون الأسرة فريقًا ،
حسنًا أظهر لنا أفضل ما لديك.
أنت جاهز ،
هل يمكننا أن نكون سوبرمان ،
لذا أعطتني أمي بعض النصائح واستغرق الأمر
وقتًا طويلاً لتنفيذها ، لكنني
فعلت ذلك في النهاية ، وعندما تصل إلى
المنزل ، قم فقط برمي حقائبك التي تعرفها
إلى الجانب ، ضع هاتفك
وتركيز  على أطفالك وهذا
يملأهم ، وبالمناسبة ، وجدت أنه
يملأني أيضًا ، اعتدت أن أذهب إلى
المنزل وأقلق بشأن ما إذا كانت البقالة
تضع جانباً ما سأقوم بإعداده
لتناول العشاء ، فإن ما يحتاجون إليه حقًا
هو  الأم أو والدهم
، وهناك أيضًا بحث يدعم
هذا الأمر في الأكاديمية الأمريكية
لطب الأطفال يقول إنه حتى خمس دقائق فقط
من وقت اللعب تقطع شوطًا طويلاً بالنسبة لطفلك ،
هناك شيء آخر ساعدني حقًا
في الأبوة والأمومة وهو تعلم إعطاء كل
طفل القليل  القليل من الوقت المنفرد ، هذا
كتاب لوكا للمدرسة ، من الواضح أنني
لا أستطيع أن أفعل ذلك بدون زوجي
بدون رعاية أطفالنا الرائعة ، فهي تأخذ
قرية ، لكنني وجدت
أن التركيز عليهم
وحدهم عندما يكون بإمكانك أن يصنع أحدهم
عالم من الاختلاف لأنهم يشعرون بأنهم
سمعوا بشكل صحيح ،
سأقول 20
21. أنا أفوز يا أمي ، أنت لست 20 ،
كم عمرك
ثلاثة أعني أنه عام
2021 وأخيراً
امتنان
ولكن هذا شيء
علمني إياه أطفالي  أكثر مما علمتهم ،
لذا في يوم من الأيام ، عادت سيينا إلى المنزل من المدرسة
مع مجلة الامتنان هذه وأنا أشعر
بالذهول من قبل معلميها اللامعين الذين
فكروا في هذا الأمر ،
أنا ممتن لـ Nia لأنها
صديقة لطيفة
ماذا عن أمي وأبي  و luca هل
حصلنا على أي حب هنا ، ربما
ستجد أنك لم تكتشف ذلك بعد ، ثم
أخبرتني أمي على ما يبدو عندما كنت في
الثالثة من عمري على مائدة العشاء ،
قلت إنني ممتن للأبقار لأنها
تعطي  لي الحليب ثلاثة
أعتقد أن هؤلاء كانوا أطفالي
علمني شيئًا للمساعدة في جعلني
أبًا أفضل ، وهذا يعني أن أكون ممتنًا
للأشياء الصغيرة ، ممتنًا
للحظات في خضم الفوضى
لأنه لا يوجد يوم من الأبوة والأمومة كما
كنت تخطط
لذلك يقول هذا الشخص
أنني ممتن للوقت مع  أمي
لأني أحب الذهاب إلى استوديو الفن
معها
[موسيقى]